you
unless you've lived under a rock for the
past several years you've most likely
seen or at least heard of the Hunger
Games series set in a dystopian future
the series pits young people against one
another in a battle to the death this
deadly game genre is not new in film and
other media and in the real world it
dates back to at least gladiatorial
combat in ancient Rome our species seems
to have a sort of morbid attraction to
death games and given our proclivity for
increasingly violent entertainment it's
prompted some to ask the question are we
headed towards a future where these
death games are the norm let's take a
trip back to ancient Rome the birthplace
of the common phrase bread and circuses
this expression originated as a jab at
the Roman citizens for caring about
nothing but cheap entertainment as a
distraction from the troubles of the
real world politicians who wanted to
ensure their position were only too
happy to oblige
throwing lavish games and handing out
free bread to the commoners to keep them
satisfied as a little side note bread
and circuses in the original Latin is
Panem at curtain --ss and you'll notice
that the name of the fictional nation in
The Hunger Games is Panem the phrase
bread and circuses doesn't necessitate
violent expositions like the ones often
seen at the Coliseum but to the Roman
leadership death games allowed them to
kill two birds with one stone the
obvious benefit was keeping the citizens
happy and distracted from their poor
living conditions but it also allowed
them to dispose of political and
military prisoners in brutal fashion
simple battle Royales were commonplace
but the Romans weren't shy of gruesome
special events either battles with wild
animals and historical reenactments were
immensely popular with the masses at
least once the entire basin of the
Colosseum was filled with water in order
to stage a naval battle complete with
ships aquatic animals and hundreds of
combatants ancient Rome was home to the
greatest heights of debauchery and it's
not surprising that we haven't seen a
spectacle quite the same as those held
at the Colosseum in our modern society
that being said our collective interest
in the idea of death games has remained
films like the most dangerous game
battle royale The Hunger Games and the
upcoming Belko experiments are evidenced
that somewhere deep down we like the
idea of this ultimate test of survival
of course we could never have such a
violent event in real life today
could we well you might be surprised as
of late 2016 an eccentric Russian
millionaire has been preparing to launch
his own televised unscripted survival
game
he looks the part all he's missing is a
scar and an exotic pet and he'd be the
perfect Bond villain the show dubbed
game to winter will be the first 24/7
live broadcast of this sort in history
it's scheduled to last for nine months
through the sweltering summer and brutal
Siberian winter 30 competitors from
around the world will be dropped on a
remote Siberian island of about nine
square kilometers with nothing but a
knife and 100 kilograms of supplies the
only goal is to survive until the end of
the nine months at surface level it just
seems like a more intense version of the
American show survivor until you look at
the rules or lack thereof because there
really aren't any restrictions the
official rules originally stated
everything is allowed fighting alcohol
murder rape smoking anything after being
pressed on the issue of whether the
organizers would step in if the cameras
were to catch a violent crime happening
The Millionaire responded no we won't we
are not scared of negative reaction if
that happens either however no matter
how intense this man wants his show to
be he's made it clear that participants
will still be subject to Russian
criminal law if they commit a crime and
it's captured by any of the 2000 cameras
in the arena they will be arrested even
with that safeguard in place the fact of
the matter is that the game itself is
incredibly dangerous even without human
violence Siberia is home to deadly
predators including gray wolves and
grizzly bears and the temperature can
range from a sweltering 35 degrees
Celsius in the summer to below minus 40
in the winter contestants will have to
forage and hunt for their own food and
craft a shelter to survive the elements
each contestant will be given a panic
button to press in case of emergency
which is linked to a GPS satellite so a
rescue helicopter can airlift them to
safety of course if you press the button
you lose the game and miss out on the
chance of winning the 1.3 million dollar
prize game - winter is slated to run
from July of 2017 to April of 2018 and
there has reportedly been interest from
mainstream television networks to air
the show in five countries and six
languages whether it will be as violent
and brutal as some predict is yet to be
seen if game to winter is a success it
would open the door for similar projects
and possibly be the catalyst for more
gruesome spectacles in the future that
leads us back to the question how
violent can it get should we expect to
see a real-life Hunger Games in the
future
one scientific journal seems to think so
tourism expert Daniel William Mackenzie
write of the university of central
lancashire suspected that within the
next 200 years we'll see a dramatic
shift towards hunting humans as a form
of sport and entertainment the paper
examines current socio-political trends
environmental degradation and depletion
of natural resources economic realities
regarding the division between the very
poor and the social elite the evolution
of theme parks and the current
depictions of deadly games in film
television and other media the author
draws the rather shocking conclusion
that by the Year 2200 death games will
make up at least a portion of the
tourism and entertainment industry with
the biggest drivers being a
desensitization to violent death thanks
to the media and the economic divide
with the ultra wealthy conducting what
would equate to human Fox honks if we as
a species get to a point where we have
accepted death as a form of
entertainment that would give world
governments a way to alleviate prison
overpopulation quell starvation in
impoverished parts of the world and keep
their citizens in check with the looming
possibility of their being selected to
participate in one of these deadly games
of course too many becoming numb to
human death and suffering would mean
losing the very essence of being human
if we kill our own kind for sport or
pleasure what separates us from animals
is it worth losing our sense of
compassion to solve some difficult
problems only time will tell but maybe
we should brush up on our archery just
in case if you'd like to learn more
about the history and future of deadly
games check out the links in the
description make sure to subscribe if
you haven't already follow second
thought on your favorite social media
and leave a comment down below with what
you think of the idea of a real-life
Hunger Games you can watch my previous
video by clicking here or watch them all
by clicking here thanks for watching and
I'll see you in the next video
you